Elton John is about to see his life
story lay out on the big screen and you
know what's really cool Kingsman start
Aaron Edgerton transforms into Elton he
even sings all the songs and only ET was
first on the set of Rocket Man I heard
that Elton hand pictured you sort of
forget that fact when you're in the
middle of shooting whole thing to have
Elton
kind of give his blessing yeah obviously
it means a huge deal there are moments
in a rockstars life that define who he
is so you kind of feel that Elton vibe
were you kind of like it's definitely
empowering yeah you kind of fit gives
you that swaggering kind of stage
persona thing
[Music]
the first trailer dropped today Tarun
takes on the singing duties in Rocket
Man
the musical fantasy about Sir Elton
John's rise to fame a lot of people
don't know that you're a great singer
yeah I love it I mean it started off as
shower singing and came drunken singing
and now I'm kind of doing it as part of
my acting life which is great
[Music]
Elton said he loves your voice what does
that mean to hear his blessing John yeah
you're singing can I say and we're a
generous man thank so we cannot wait for
people to see turn in this movie now
remember Elton had a role in Kingsman in
a sequel and it's actually where he and
Taryn first met they got along and now
look at this
[Music]